let's see struggling Chandra through a
fight this is a public high school in
the United States of America they're
literally could not be a better place to
buy Campbell are you serious
oh man
how they do the guidance counselor don't
do mess no more home with matt got it no
mess period when I'm on my period don't
do it if I needed the most just fine
read it off every 17 adinath a new
teacher babies between a game equal the
street
I'm gonna fight you I'm sorry what you
ratted on me he did it as you got to pay
the price tell me most of you lose bone
not all the sets out of you there's no
punching sex out of me haha despite
rated R her boy 17 Isis is this a
practical jokes ah [ __ ] don't have money
for books we got money for this weird
angle all you gotta do is put in your
order and undressed coffee you're gonna
[ __ ] that coffee machine over I know our
rough school but this is the voice I've
ever seen the Franks something weird
about this field you're standing on a
giant dick man you brought a control
think this is funny letting the TV with
your goddamn kapoor to telephone a
weirdo Amy's kids grow up and then one
Dame it's just like BAM they're 18 you
can [ __ ] them
he stupid [ __ ] on the school all day oh
and don't nobody do nothing i'm going to
show you what I can't wait to [ __ ] you
up I'm sorry what we're gonna handle our
differences like real meaning what
differences you got a job and not don't
that's the fun dip challenge mr.
Campbell to a fistfight I'll see you at
three o'clock here's a nice guy and that
people are like hey I'm going to stop on
that guy no girl is going not all the
sets out of you distance is holding
you're not just arrest a guy care to
respond [ __ ] the police did they got it
all hopped up on homemade mess around
the best bet well I'm sorry how do you
know how do I know what you're the
guidance counselor don't do math period
when I'm not here you don't do it if I
needed the most done with this [ __ ] [ __ ]
me camels got a book right back thank
God get in a fist fight
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] sons of [ __ ]
this is getting violent I look like a
[ __ ] million
[Music]
I
you